oh my god I think I might cry I know I
feel the tears this is how locals do
make it this might be the meal that
breaks it I'm in Las Vegas Las Vegas is
one of the most exciting food cities in
the country and wherever you look
there's a great place to eat my friend
Allison is going to show me some of her
favorites on and off the strip let's
come here
Allison so good to see you too so where
are we we're at chuckles Oporto it's a
favorite among tourists and us locals
like you too let's get in line it's so
long already
[Music]
hello my name is solo I am manager of
operations here at the coastal Bordeaux
it's service trailer Street that goes
back in the late 60s in Mexico we have
been in Vegas since 2010 and it's still
a family-owned and operated business
till Tuesday so spicy pork taco is one
of our most popular items it's actually
two tortillas and then you put it on the
grease a little bit and then you put the
buy support marinated ahead of time with
a lot of Mexican spices and really
strong flavors we like to use a special
family recipe deep it's welcome all the
base a little bit of a sweet flavor on
it cilantro and white onion if you come
here for the first time or even your
12th time we want you to have the same
kind of experiences leave overall with a
great taste in your mouth so we'll start
off with a spicy pork
all of them are marinating in-house
let's think about you
Wow they're so flavorful and it's nice
and spicy but not cool
I got a cake but it doesn't feel
overpower no no no it's spiced I can
handle it feels like just so balanced at
tortillas itself have like a really good
bite to it it's a lot of meat in here
which is great it really just feels like
this incredible combination of flavors
coming together
Takuya asada steak taco we only use one
tortilla on this taco so it's a
different kind of tortilla even though
it's based on the same kind of dope made
by hand and we put meat and also family
recipe sauce it comes with cilantro and
what I mean is the one so these are the
carne asada tacos it's so you can tell
it's picture perfection
handmade tortillas are always really
special but they just have a different
bite to it and I mean this is a
late-night spot too right yes I feel
like coming here at 4:00 in the morning
sigh man he definitely needs some tacos
in your life this is a place to country
the corner start off fresh is regular
french fresh and you put some meat on
top and also white cheese and yellow
cheese
it comes with famous welcome only base
dip sour cream that we prepare yourself
and you can also put mashed avocado in
there just as it is okay fast save the
best for last
these are carne asada fries I was
introduced to these fries probably about
three years ago your face is lit up
right now you are easy I'm so that's how
much I have a look pretty surprised wow
this is what I want late at night
gracious
there's all this carnage Alison this has
been great
where we off to next I think I have
somewhere in mind something you've never
seen before which houses all of our neon
marquise tiny asian miss me in Las Vegas
back in the day so just because it's not
a photo strip now it's in this beautiful
museum to give people an opportunity so
really just see historic Las Vegas is
all about on the strip everything is so
new and flashy and this feels like you
know it's like a part of history
yeah and nostalgia just to see what this
once looked like in like the 1940s and
he's like having that I wish we could go
back no but this feels like you are I
love bringing people here just so they
can get a taste of what old Vegas was
really like so cool it's amazing this
place is literally the best place to get
Thai food it's amazing my name is penny
and shettima motor stops I'm originated
in Vegas about 50 years ago and it's
basically Thai food but many people
think is just basic Thai food like pad
Thais chow mein but honestly it's more
than that chef is very passionate about
where she's from she's originally from
the northern Thai so most of the dishes
that you find here are what you would
eat in the northern region my father
started a very big wine program many
people are actually pretty shocked that
a Thai restaurant will have an extensive
wine list like we do I tried to give the
fine-dining experience without the
fine-dining price prick it is a mushroom
dip that many people in Chiang Mai would
eat so right here we'll have all the
essentials for the chili dip broccoli
cauliflower carrots green bean cucumber
as well as steamed cabbage this one is
the green chili dip so numb freakin old
is made with smoked Anaheim peppers
tomatoes and smoked garlic and then
afterwards she puts in three different
types of mushrooms quinoa char mushrooms
shiitakes and
mushrooms we saute them first add a just
a bit of lime juice and then a little
bit of salt water just to give it a tiny
bit of saltiness and then afterwards
she'll top it off with cilantro as well
as green onions that's already mixed
inside the NAMM called Todd what she's
adding right now is gonna be our lime
sauce our freshly ground chili powder
that is our house-made sour sausage as
well as onions and ginger cilantro and
green onions as well you'll also have
the peanuts the special mixture crispy
rice we actually have our special
marinade for it it's a family secret in
a general sense one of those when you
get married you'll have it kind of
ordeal once she's mix everything
together plate it and then dried chilli
right on top comes out as the namco talk
I love the flavors it's not too spicy
and they make this sausage in-house so
you know it's gonna be good most of the
crispy rice sauce I've had don't have
you know pork in it and it actually adds
this like warm Valley right flavor yet
and it cuts some of the heat which is
really really nice never had a mushroom
dip before it's so good it's very light
it has great depth of flavor
again there's heat but not too much so
this is the roasted duck curry and it
has duck pieces as well as grapes
pineapple then afterwards what they'll
do is they'll add the red bell pepper
and green bell pepper to the mixture as
well the liquid is the curry some Thai
basil into it and then afterwards we'll
put in cherry tomatoes that have already
been split we also add a little bit of
red wine to it as well usually you can
find this over in central Thailand so in
Bangkok area and then to top it off they
put on basil right on top and it serve
just that way I think everyone knows by
now that I'm a really big fan of duck so
this is really exciting for me delicious
taste the peppers it's sweeter my smell
warm inside yes and then this is her
waiting the pork stew pork stew is made
by curing for about three and a half
hours in the chili as well as with red
onions garlic and ginger you have two
portions you have the pork butts as well
as the pork belly so you'll have not
only just the meaty portion we also have
the fattiness then afterwards she put
cilantro right on top and you have the
brookson let's try the fork it's me
again the pork is melting in your mouth
he knows to say it's just falling off
and it's just oh it's so so succulent
off they're both good but I really like
this thoughtful problem I really
appreciate that everything isn't too
spicy you can taste all the flavors but
it's not overwhelming your mouth this is
how locals do make it just about
[Music]
we're almost at the top of the high
roller which is the largest observation
wheel in the world 550 feet speeds and
so this is probably my favorite things
to bring people to because you get to
see all of Las Vegas the view is so
beautiful it is so I feel like when I
when I look down I start to like slow it
handle but I got Romo stepped up I'm
like panicking a little bit but it's
really really cool all the strength so
we're at Caesar's Palace which is the
most iconic place for this trip and
we're about to go into restaurant get
some [ __ ] the most exclusive restaurant
in Las Vegas
are you ready you're so ready but this
is so great good evening tonight
great good evening more swap welcome to
the crew chef's table at restaurant Giza
walk I hope you came hungry yes always
hi my name is Julie Asti I'm the
executive chef of restaurant visa walk
here at Caesar's Palace in Las Vegas the
restaurant cassava is a mission star
award restaurant for French fine dining
or cooking means that we don't put away
the classics of French cuisine but we
just innovate
everything's catered to create a
memorable experience so that our guests
leave with a big smile my face what
about some butter for tonight that is
the most insane butter ever this is
crazy radical having a tasting menu in a
kitchen like this with the chef's right
here this feels
next-level special I'm in awe just with
the braid can you imagine when they're
red so the first dish is we're gonna do
today so it's take on a tomato salad
we're gonna find some thinly sliced
heirloom tomato yellow and red
watermelon with some beautiful aged
sherry vinegar I love sherry vinegar
because it's not too sweet and we have
some extra virgin olive oil and then
we'll finish with a little bit of
flawless set which is a fine sea salt
that they collect on top of the salt
crops and then a little bit of black
pepper a mignonette will go with this
dish is to kind of like trick you into
not thinking that it's watermelon it
actually looks like tomato and then
we're gonna have some heirloom tomato
pope and then we have some bloom basil
seed that we marinade with some
beautiful green bay
oil vinegar caviar which is a
purification of balsamic vinegar to a
little pop micro basil chips to add a
little texture and so now to finish I'm
going to add a kernel of the gas petrol
sorbet gasps matcha which is pretty much
you know like a tomato soup and then
some really nice cucumber blossom and
there it is
to finish we're going to post team the
dish with a little bit basil water I am
not wearing me I feel so overwhelmed
this is one of the most beautiful pipes
that has ever been put in front of me oh
my god I think I might cry I know I feel
it here oh my gosh if anyone dreams
about Tomatoes this is how they should
taste it's like sweet and juicy and it
feels like it was plucked off the vine
minutes ago we can definitely tell when
they prepared it they really paid
attention to every detail so next we're
gonna have the artichoke and black
truffle soup which is our signature dish
I'm going to start by adding a little
bit of grated Parmesan from Italy right
here I have the actual soup which is a
water based soup I'm going to finish by
adding some shaving of Australia and
winter truffle and then I'm also gonna
add some of the parmesan and then this
soup wouldn't be the soup without its
famous toast a mushroom brioche everyone
knows about this this is what I've been
hearing like and if the brioche in the
soup and have to eat it that way
so first before you even taste it it's
this aroma of truffles that is you know
filling this entire room and what a
treat I'm died and gone to heaven oh my
gosh I don't know who made that brioche
wait I want to shake their hand how is
this so creamy and contains no dairy
they're angels back there making this
food I just can't believe how amazing is
then the next dish is going to be our
lobster dish and we're gonna cook it
with butter and then at the end finish
it with a lobster Roe butter I'm gonna
add a little bit of that butter right on
top pull out of this show see it comes
right off
right here we have ravioli made from
corn puree and then we cut some small
pieces from the lobster clock and then
with some slightly roasted corn kernels
all right here we have some basil puree
and we also have some baseball bud we
have a corn foam and then right here is
some very interesting
pork rind but we made it from a tapioca
and reduced lobster stock and we serve
it with a netiquette lobster juice and
cheese with basil oil the corners in
season it's coming through the lobster
it's a classic combination but done just
in the very best way if I don't have
ravioli mate like me it's so fantastic
to see a chef that's using every single
part of the animal using the shell for
the stock the tail using all the parts
of it it makes the flavors more
concentrated you definitely gotta take
the Vegas in this dish then we're gonna
move into the beef so we do a variation
of beef American Wagyu and so we use the
rib cap and the short ribs so one is
cooked for 72 hours so really slow and
you know and very tender and the other
one is just seared and finished on the
beach was unreal so I'm going to see
then the rib eye so I'm going to start a
little bit of oil and see all sites so
any capsulate although all the good
juice they sting a little bit of butter
everything tastes better with butter
well fish in the oven so you have more
even cooking so we have the short rib
right here which has been glazed in a
little bit of the cooking juice that we
reduced to make it nice and shiny on top
of the rib cap I'm going to add a little
condiment made from shallots bone marrow
and deglaze a little bit of vinegar so
this is our in the center or potato
onion and for rainbow terrine so you
have all the three different components
and so now we're ready to paint and then
just to garnish we have some little
micro chive batons and then a potato
chip net we will finish with the
Bordelaise juice is reduced that we make
from austell red wine black pepper and
veal stock like the demi glass oh what a
pity
oh I gotta get my game face on it is
this better tune because
it's so creamy the short rib isn't
credible if we can only always have a
cute short oh my gosh oh it's so rich
just falling apart
this combination steak and potatoes
classic combination but none of this
feels average or boring no effective
this feels like familiar flavors that
are just elevated I think like anyone
could appreciate and then last but not
least is our fig dessert which is you
know different textures of figs we're
gonna start with an orange creme
anglaise which is like a soft make from
a egg sugar and milk some orange in
there as well then we're gonna find a
almond tuile it's flour sugar egg white
and almond flour then we're gonna find
some fig puree and then blend it until
you have something smooth some almond
slivered fig has to be nice and ripe to
really showcase or for potential orange
segments so we just go feed them a
little bit of a syrup and it's just the
skin and the almonds some fresh thyme
and I'm gonna finish the desserts with
almond milk sorbet
we call it the cuisine from the Sun
which is you know different textures of
figs around the plate is with different
flavors and texture of the fig to really
showcase the ingredients everything is
just paired very nicely the textures the
sweetness but the orange balance the
juiciness of the fig the cool of the
sorbet which I know you like scream is
of the creme anglaise and the almonds
it's really just divine
I loved what they did with the almond
because it's not overpowering it's just
like a hint I really like it this is
amazing
this is totally worth saving up for oh
yeah I had so many awesome experiences
to choose from in Vegas and now I get to
choose how to pay for them with peut
Planet from American Express having the
food we made right here for us
the chef tailor this to us it feels so
special its own unique I can't thank you
enough thank you for coming with me
like swole up nearly
[Music]